all right so I've been researching the
FUNimation Blu-rays and the DVDs but on
my way to doing so discovered something
that was honestly bizarre I thought I
was one of the people who was in the
know concerning the redubbing of those
few seasons but
this isn't the show that we remember oh
no okay so look take this for example
okay this is
originally back in the day for those
that didn't know well now you've got it
huh you're not as dumb as you look seems
normal right yeah because it is it is
normal okay this is what's actually on
Modern box sets
now you've got it
at least you're not as dumb as I am what
at least you're not as dumb as I am I
have no I have no idea how there isn't a
big video on YouTube about this
how and this is because just wait for it
FUNimation secretly changed a whole lot
about their dub of Dragon Ball Z when
the show came to DVD and Blu-ray and
it's come to my attention that no one on
YouTube seems to be covering it until
today last week on the channel we went
through the ins and outs of Dragon Ball
Z's DVD releases and how they all are
kind of cursed in one way or several but
one of the most common comments we
received on that video was about which
version people could experience their
childhood with AKA which version has the
English dub with the Bruce faulconer
music that hit all of her Collective
Airways when Britney Spears was hitting
our babies one more time well I've got
good news and bad news and the good news
is if all you are after is hearing the
FUNimation Dub with the Faulkner music
then basically every single DVD in
Blu-ray you can get your hands on has
you covered wow short video right go
team wrong because you're forgetting the
bad news and the bad news is that it's a
lot more complicated than just that
because here's the thing
those changes I mentioned there's a lot
of them and some of them are the most
insane stuff I have ever seen come out
of a professional production these
secret changes were not advertised they
weren't mentioned in a blog post hell
some of them I am 99 certain FUNimation
doesn't even realize they changed to
begin with so drop in folks because I
fell deep down into the rabbit hole of
the FUNimation dub and discovered some
things that no one seems to have covered
in detail before and by the end I think
I may have gone a little clinically
insane
[Music]
where do I even begin here you see the
further I dove down this proverbial
Rabbit Hole as I tirelessly researched
for this video the more and more
differences I uncovered we've got big
stuff like redubs of entire Seasons
changes to character voices Rewritten
scripts accidentally putting lines in
the wrong place I'll get to that but
yeah just the whole nine yards so I
guess I'll start with the stuff they did
on purpose and yes be prepared for the
on accident stuff later because it gets
wild uh let's take a look at the very
first and most obvious change they made
the voices and that all started with
replacing the ocean dub yeah that rock
the dragon intro you just listened to
was probably a blast in the past hey
been a while since you've heard that one
well there's actually a very good reason
for that some of this you might already
know but it's worth repeating for
context prior to the shimmels and
sabbats of the modern era Dragon Ball Z
in its first few seasons had a
completely different set of voice actors
and music most people know this but it
actually had a lot of consequences for
the dub that came after this first dub
was called the Pioneer or ocean dub and
it was still headed up by FUNimation at
the time but contracted out to the
canadian-based company ocean group for
their voice actors and music and thus
you get the rock the dragon intro and
the different music done by Ron
Wasserman and all the different voice
actors
over nine thousand what then of course
after a few seasons FUNimation decided
to take the reins at which point we
swapped over to the voice cast and music
that we all know and love today Sean
schimel Christopher Sabbath the falconer
score the whole crew was on board from
season three on and everything was
peachy keen the problem came a few years
later when for the first time they
decided to release an entire box set for
the whole series because as you can
imagine marathoning your box set at home
and suddenly having Vegeta go from
sounding like this so it happened after
3 000 years another Super Saiyan has
emerged to this
oh they don't deserve any favors the
scum Kakarot believe me would be quite
the jarring experience so their solution
was to go back to those first couple
seasons and basically just redo the
whole thing from scratch they heated the
old voices and music had the FUNimation
voice crew go back and redo all the
lines with pretty much the exact same
script it's over nine thousand and thus
the complete FUNimation dub was born the
entire cast member used to was there in
full force for the San Arc and while the
falconer score did not reprise its role
for the soundtrack they did hire Nathan
Johnson who is now literally a state
senator by the way to compose an updated
soundtrack for The Arc that was intended
to transition into the later Falconer
score a little more gracefully than the
original ocean score did in addition to
all of this while they were doing the
redubs for the first two seasons they
figured it was a pretty good opportunity
to go back and clean up some of their
let's say less polished performances
from their original dub of the third
season Dynamics great you can't beat it
yeah good old Namek where balls are born
now I joke but a lot of the changes to
season 3's dub were not so much trying
to fix bad performances but instead more
so trying to deal with a specific Quirk
of that third season because well let's
step back and think about things
chronologically for a second it's the
late 90s ocean group had just finished
dubbing two seasons of their show with
their own cast and FUNimation is now
taking over the dub with their new
actors but for the audience at home
they're not privy to any of this they
are just sitting there slurping up their
animals like usual turning on to the
next episode of this sick new cartoon
they've been watching and so
funimation's goal with their new dub
cast was to sort of have their voices
almost be imitations of the ocean dub
and as a result the voices from the
FUNimation crew sound very weird in that
first season they dubbed to what we all
know today Sean shiml's Goku sounded
like this there's no need to be scared
of me just say you're sorry for what
you've done and leave and no harm will
come to you Christopher Sabbath's Vegeta
was a lot higher pitch to match Brian
Drummond's Vegeta don't think I did this
to save your puny hives I had my own
score from long ago to settle with that
froggish four-eyed freak I remember
those guys if you think they're going to
tip the scale in your favor then you're
out of your mind if you're going to make
a wish make it a doozy unfreeze's entire
casting was largely just trying to match
what came before but again if you're
marathoning these new box sets they were
trying to put out what's the experience
going to be like you're going to watch
two seasons of funimation's redub where
everyone sounds how you expect with
their new redone dub then you hit season
three and boom suddenly Vegeta sounds
like a teenager so to combat this
FUNimation went through and had a lot of
the dialogue from some of their most
Stand Out voices we recorded to fit
better with the rest of the series and I
mean this sort of makes sense season 3
was voiced in such a way that matched
the original ocean dub but we don't have
that anymore so the new dub from that
point on was required therefore the
version you watch at home now instead of
this Vegeta that's the dragon of the
legend my gosh that's one Whopper of a
lizard you get this Vegeta
they summoned him the earthlings have
tried to summon the dragon of Legend
without me with all of that said we have
now reached a point in the video where
everything begins to go a little off the
rails and begin to fall into a
never-ending pit of insanity with no
guarantee of return to mental stability
passengers must keep their hands and
arms inside the vehicle and remain
seated at all times because so far
everything has made Pretty Good Sense
redubbing the ocean Seasons sure redoing
some of those weird or bad voices from
season three yeah makes sense sounds
like these box sets are ready to go
because now we have entered the oopsie
Daisy FUNimation did a little funky
Wookie section of the video in classic
FUNimation fashion they seem to be
permanently incapable of releasing
Dragon Ball Z for the home audience
without breaking things along the way
and oh boy did they break a lot here
let's start with my personal favorite
line flubs the clip back at the very
beginning of the video with Piccolo
declaring how dumb he is is obviously a
good example to start with here I have
no idea how that made it in past the
filtering process of Funimation whether
it be a complete accident or a cheap she
can turn sneaking in a funny outtake but
it is the is there check your DVD if you
don't believe me at least you're not as
dumb as I am and this sort of thing
isn't even a one-off multiple times
while digging through these releases I
would come across lines that are just
not meant to be there at all like this
bit in episode 36 where King Kai is
explaining the history of Planet Namek
but then suddenly is talking about the
history of the Saiyans on planet Vegeta
wants a very beautiful place it was very
much like the Earth guys and green with
an abundance of rice in the Arid
wastelands of Vegeta the Saiyans lived
in primitive fashion I did some digging
and this line is meant to be from
episode 20 when naturally King Kai has
explained the history of the Saiyans
once again I just have to imagine that
this is either the result of a rush
production or some funny little
FUNimation in turn having a laugh if
only that was where the mistakes ended
however next we have an entire category
of music changes a lot of folks like to
bully the falconer score online and to
them I say that FUNimation has literally
gone and made the music purposely worse
in these home releases compared to what
aired originally take this clip for
example everyone is up on the lookout
wistfully remembering the life of Goku
as he has agreed to stay dead and in the
original broadcast the music that plays
here is a lovely track that is just
packed the brim with emotion and
Nostalgia yeah well Goku's been that way
ever since he was little
[Music]
it's like nothing ever got to him then
as if by an act of intentional sabotage
you have the music that plays in the
home releases yeah Will Goku's been that
way ever since he was little
[Music]
it's like nothing ever got to him yep
that's right gone are the sweet Dosa
tones of that music and in its place is
this standard dire flashback music stuff
like this is honestly everywhere you
almost literally cannot go through a
single episode without some sort of
musical change the scene with Goku
having a nightmare about the Androids
well while the original matches that
tone with some appropriately creepy
music
stop it stop it right now the box sets
seem to think this is a comedy scene
stop it right now and don't even get me
started on how these box sets love to
replace music with the perfect selfie Mr
Perfect so going back and checking the
earlier versions I was really Blown Away
by how much more diverse the music was
in the original in general like don't
get me wrong the theme is cool really
cool I'm down for some
dude
they can only use it so many times
before I begin to lose what's left of my
reason all of this isn't even to mention
the bigger changes like replacing the
opening and eye catch music
[Music]
then aside from all of this there are
the changes made to the audio mixing
itself in what was presumably an effort
to fix up some of the relatively sloppy
mixing of the third season FUNimation
overhauled all the mixing for the entire
series and the consequences of this are
yeah the music fluctuates from being too
quiet too way too loud the
voices are often mixed poorly changing
in value from shot to shot but I think
the most impactful change of their
overhaul to the mixing is the loss of
almost all of the vocal effects honestly
at this point I'm not sure if this was
on purpose or on accident I'm more apt
to think it's an accident given that
their GT box sets still have these
effects but for some reason just about
any and all vocal effects are completely
absent in these box sets now that can
range from small stuff like people no
longer sounding like they're talking
through a telephone or flashbacks no
longer having that iconic Reverb sound
to very big things like character voices
completely changing for example from
Super Buu on there was a subtle deep
voice filter effect that was applied
over everything boo said to make him
sound a bit more menacing you're just a
little sucker whereas now in the box
sets that is absent and boo sort of
sounds like a teenager you're just a
little sucker even worse than that
though is what they did to poor Android
19. originally he had a voice filter
that made him sound very robot-esque to
emphasize how he was kind of an early
model I guess I don't know don't ask me
I'm not trying to get into the minds of
1990s FUNimation and while I personally
think that filter was a bit silly the
problem is that when they remove that
filter they didn't think to re-record
the lines here so now we have these
original line reads
that were intended for a crazy filter
that just sound completely silly without
them we will destroy it
yes 20. it's really hard to express just
how much the audio mixing is a disaster
in these releases between this and the
famously awful video quality I very much
get the impression that the original
orange bricks were just rushed out the
door and their audio quality suffered as
a result which makes even more sense now
given that around the buark Not only was
there video color accuracy improving but
a lot of these mistakes and errors were
starting to go away you still had things
like voice filters being absent or
missing elements of the mixing like
iconic delayed Reverb effect of people
talking the Time Chamber but at the very
least the outright bad audio levels and
misplaced lines were mostly a thing of
the past and yet somehow were still not
through because in addition to the
messed up lines the ruined audio mixing
the purposely worse music placement and
the missing voice effects we have the
final phase of funimation's quest to
drive me into a mental institution the
added lines see once again we're in a
situation where one of the things people
make fun of about the FUNimation dub
that being the fact that it can never
shut the up and let there be
silence is actually largely a product of
their changes to the box sets themselves
all over these things just about any
time there's a long stint of Silence
they add previously non-existent
dialogue from someone off screen to fill
the void Majin Vegeta powering up to his
extremely sick attack against Majin Buu
while the original had only silence
Ambient sound effects and suspenseful
music the box sets decided that every
DBZ viewer has the attention span of a
South Irish squirrel now instead we are
treated to Bobbidi yelling endlessly at
boo through the entire process not
leaving even a moment for me to let the
bad thoughts in show him what happens to
people who blow out my spaceship
are you
not an isolated example added lines
where there was one silence is a near
constant throughout these home releases
and it just I just
um look I am not trying to be an old man
yelling at a cloud here I am generally
speaking a guy that just likes to kick
back and enjoy his TV in the living room
and to be honest half of what I'm
describing in this video are not
necessarily objectively bad things
though the bad mixing flood lines added
lines missing effects Etc are in fact
bad most of this is more along the lines
of huh looking at what changed is neat a
fun little ROM through the changes that
FUNimation has made both on purpose and
on accident through the years of putting
the series to box sets but after last
week's video with the torture that is
having no release of Dragon Ball that I
can reliably recommend to any fan of the
show old or new it is just insane to
find that well of mistakes goes even
further can we please just have one
great release one measly released Master
FUNimation in which the video looks how
it's supposed to the audio sounds how
it's supposed to nothing insane is added
or taken away and it's all as it should
be I just I just want to be able to
watch the show as it was intended oh
wait what am I thinking I barely watch
anime I Read Manga whatever
[Music]
foreign